un match pour rester dans la course à la
montée vélizy recevait saint-avertin les
derniers du classement pour le compte de
la 7ème journée de nationale 3 karl en
place tactiquement les béliziens
remporte les deux premiers sets sur les
scores de 25 22 et 25 21
premier set c'était un petit peu
compliqué au début quand même on en n'a
pas su à prendre le dessus sur le
rapport service recept à la fin on a
fait le petit décalage deuxième set dont
a bien déroulé dans le troisième set les
joueurs de florian guillossou sont plus
en difficulté il arrive finalement
l'emporter 29 à 27 après avoir failli
concéder le set
bilan de cette rencontre trois sets à
zéro sur le troisième set il ya eu un
réveil de l'équipe adverse nous a pas
facilité la tâche qui a bien servi nous
on a fait des petites des petites
erreurs un peu bêtes et ballon qui tombe
sans personnes se jettent dessus c'était
compliqué mais on a su à la fin
resserrer les vis cette victoire permet
à l'équipe d'occuper la troisième place
du classement avec un bilan de cinq
victoires en sept journées disputées
des résultats qui permettent au club de
regarder vers le haut du classement
l'objectif primordial c'est le maintien
déjà la dre qui peut le moins peut le
plus on va dire donc si on peut aller
chercher quelque chose de
montée en fin de saison où une place sur
le podium
on s'en privera pas pour rêver toujours
plus grands les vélizy un se déplaceront
le 12 janvier sur le teint de cercle
jules-ferry les premiers du classement
en attendant le club passera de belles
fêtes de fin d'année
[Applaudissements]